briefly describe what will be the
schedule for the full program
so the program will start on monday
july 12th and we will start
this program in two parts
the first part we'll talk about the
introduction to big data so
what are the different types of data
what are some of the big data challenges
and opportunities
how to clean load and process data how
to perform
exploratory data analysis and then we'll
do some practical training so that we
can all try out these methods together
okay so briefly we do have a question
from christina she's saying
i've just introduced the resources
available with the starter subscription
the starter subscription will give you
access to the demo pipelines that i just
showed
and to running the code the program will
actually open up the platform for you to
load data sets and will go through ncbi
and tcga and places like that to take
curated data sets and
process them and then analyze them
together so the program subscription
will give you a higher level of access
and it's going to be a little bit more
expensive but i'll talk about that at
the end of today's session
let me know please if that answers your
question
so the program itself yes the starter
package
is a fully asynchronous training package
that you can use to
understand how the two are connected and
to practice some coding
and learn about different types of data
sets the program
will include synchronous sessions
sessions like today that are interactive
where you can ask questions and get
practical help
where you will also get much more
in-depth information than is
what is provided in the courses and what
we found is that
this is really needed to master a
subject because so many online courses
lack the guidance and the structure and
so that's why we created these programs
to provide with that structure and
mentorship
so that you can interact with a live
person and get unstuck
before you get into the program and the
program will be organized into two parts
the first part is going to be an
introduction and the second part is
going to be focused on machine learning
itself
so we'll talk about what is the
difference between machine learning and
ai
what are the different methods for
supervised and unsupervised learning
and then we'll talk about how to deal
with the multiple types of models that
are available there i mean
there are so many methods they all work
in a very similar way
how do you effectively choose between
them and select the one that will work
for the type of project that you have
and the type of objectives that you are
pursuing
in your own project and that's going to
be another important component is that
according to the levels of learning one
of the highest levels of learning
is called a project-based learning and
so
project-based learning if you really
master something that means that you can
do
a project using those methods so you
will learn about a lot of different
methods
but to test yourself and to know that
you really mastered
you need to try and apply that to an
independent project and so that will be
another component of this
program is we will help you apply this
to a project of your own
and guide you to refine your thinking
about
when and how and specifically
what does the specific analysis type
that you've chosen
address in the data set that you've
already selected that you also select so
it's going to be a flexible
thing that you can try different data
sets and try different methods
and then come up with a research
proposal and actually try and execute it
during the program
so i'll briefly review some of these
methods that i've discussed
the first part working with big
biomedical data
will include addressing some of the
different types of
omics data including different
technologies that are used to generate
that data
we will then talk about what is the
difference between
small data and big data and what are
some additional data
challenges that we are supposed to
address and how does that change
our analysis practice how do we go from
kind of typical statistical analysis to
what is the need for machine learning
we'll then go through cleaning loading
and
processing data so we'll talk about how
to prepare a table but also how to
explore that table
to know what to do with it and we will
also address some of the
important questions that arise out of
exploratory data analysis
so we look at statistical properties
we'll spot
batch effects and technical issues that
have to be
removed and addressed before we actually
start the analysis
and then we'll take a look at several
examples of how
this ties into a workflow so how to
essentially design your workflow from
acquiring data from different
repositories
to preparing a structured data for
analysis
one of the questions and maybe i can ask
this of you as well
is well transcriptomic data in a sense
is easy right
transcriptomic data is continuous and so
the numbers are right there
in the table but what to do with data
that is naturally categorical for
example here
you have sequences of t c g and a so
essentially numbers one two three and
four
how do we deal with data that is like
that to convert it
to data that is continuous that is most
useful for some of these machine
learning methods
and so the answer to that of course is
that there are many different ways that
we can convert data from categorical
to continuous and once we've done that
we need to incorporate that step of how
we convert it to data
so that our analysis matches the type of
preparation that we did
now in the second part we will talk
about data-driven analysis and that's
really where machine learning comes into
play
is because we generate a hypothesis
from data and then we build an algorithm
oftentimes
not really diving too deep into the
biology before we can train a model
that could have some meaningful value
right
and so this is a huge change from the
traditional approach to data analysis
coming from biological experimental
design
because we're essentially not trying to
test the hypothesis
we are trying to design an algorithm
that could mean
something useful either for
understanding or for
a practical use and i think that's one
of the major
kind of advantages of machine learning
in that sense because
we essentially can not understand
everything but still
find use in the data that is generated
so we'll talk about
what is machine learning and how is it
different from artificial intelligence
we'll turn to unsupervised learning
where we'll talk about
different types of clustering techniques
and what do they mean what do they
provide us with
we will talk about supervised analysis
for classification and feature selection
so that we can understand different
algorithms
different types of models and what are
they essentially
able to provide us with we will then
talk about
evaluating the different models and the
outputs through
model accuracy and validation we'll talk
about rock curves and area under curve
we'll talk about
also how to interpret some of the
results from
our analysis and how to then use these
metrics to select
the right model for what we want to
achieve
we will then talk about machine learning
to get results right so
one thing is to understand how these
methods work another one is to actually
make them work right and that's where
you have to build essentially a pipeline
and make sure that you are including all
of these important steps
into that pipeline and also so that you
have a full description of your full
code that you can share with others that
would like to try
and replicate what you have done so we
will address this
important topic in biomedical research
which has to do with reproducibility
so what are you going to learn by
joining specifically this program and
here we've listed out
some of the things that we think are
critical for
anyone that would like to learn
biomedical
data science for biomedical discovery
and that includes learning by looking at
examples of data visualization
and learning about different types of
approaches and packages for machine
learning and r and python
looking at some curated data sets and by
curated i mean these were selected from
peer-reviewed papers they contain uh
interesting kind of questions and
interesting results as well so we can
validate the analysis
you will learn about stage of stages of
analysis
exploratory comparative supervised and
unsupervised
we'll talk about different types of
machine learning algorithms
so that you understand the taxonomy and
how to read and understand different
methods
you'll also learn about fair principles
of how to
describe your analysis and share your
workflow
and you will also learn about project
design and
implementation for independent research
and i will point you to a course
actually that we have there
that can help you streamline your
bioinformatics analysis
okay a question from hidayah is it
suitable for a beginner
yes you do not need to know how to use r
if you followed our previous steps you
probably
saw that there's some asynchronous
coursework on the very basics of r how
to
learn about it um so if you are not
intimidated if you're brave and you are
up for the challenge
then this is definitely for you if you
feel like this is technically very
complex
i would recommend that you first try so
if you have some time today or tomorrow
over the weekend
you can try out some of these
asynchronous courses some of them are
free
and if it seems like something that you
can manage then definitely this is for
you
and please let me know if i answered
your question
now there are some additional benefits
that i won't go
into right now you can see them on the
screen but i do want to mention
this part of the independent project
right so as i mentioned
to really learn and master a skill
you typically have to go beyond just
reading a textbook and trying out a few
pieces of code so really it's all about
applying these methods that you've
learned to an independent project
and so to do that we've designed a
system
to help you apply the data that
we have curated or that you can find
with
methods that you will learn about or
additional methods that you have heard
about or read about
to a project where you can modify the
settings
and the question that you have and
essentially come out
with a fully independent project and we
have many examples of people that have
completed
a similar program and have come out with
a
fully completed project that they have
shared
and went on to publishing so let me show
you
what that means
on the same portal
if you look under courses
you will be able to find a project
or sorry a course about
developing an independent project called
designing a bioinformatics research
project and this is
essentially a cornerstone of our
project driven method that helps
translate these
practical skills into an outcome
that is relevant for research so a lot
of the participants that we have here
are researchers or
interested in research and to help them
start applying bioinformatics in a
meaningful way
we've designed this guide that
essentially goes from
finding a real interesting
and competitive research topic through
literature review
to then finding a data set on different
public domain repositories
and then all the way to finalizing your
analysis
and presenting this so that you are
ready for publication
so this is all a part of our strategy
and if you go to your profile you will
see
how all of these things actually connect
so the first one is training
right here under your profile you will
find a tab
called courses and you'll be able to see
that
you have a number of courses that you
can go through
complete them and get a certificate for
completing that
individual course so if you click here
it will open up and show your
certificate
the second one is in many cases it's not
enough to go through the material
independently you really have to have
someone that
guides you in a structure to get you
from point a to point b
and that is where these programs come in
now you might be
advanced and interested in machine
learning or you might be just a beginner
and just getting started
and based on where you are we've
designed specific programs to help you
get started from where you are
and get you to the next level so if
you're ready to join this program
go to lvrn armatologic data science if
you would like to just get started and
learn about
what is going on with bioinformatics we
recommend another program
called omixlogic bioinformatics and
computational biology a cheap and
affordable program for anyone interested
to get started
but ultimately we would like you to be
able to design
an independent project and so we have
these multiple steps that you have to
follow
to be able to get there you have to
complete your profile
your bio earn 10 000 points
which you acquire by going through the
different projects and the different
challenges along the way and then you
will be able to complete this course
that i just showed you
where all of the steps are given and you
can submit
a project proposal that will be reviewed
by our team
and then go through all the steps needed
to complete your analysis
and present as a research fellow
and so that's why an additional program
that we have for those of you that
already know everything that there is to
know and you would like to work on an
independent project exclusively
we have another specific program called
a research fellowship
and this program is designed to actually
help you
learn and work on your independent
uh sorry on your independent
project along the way so i'm just going
to post this link right here
for those of you that are interested in
more of a research approach to this
whole thing
this is a program that could be between
three months
and six months and during that time we
are confident that you can get to a
meaningful
outcome including a full project
proposal
and presentation
okay so that is what i wanted to cover
we have a number of examples of people
that have
completed this program and have started
using some of the bioinformatics tools
and data science skills in their
research we do have a lot of these
examples already on the website so you
can look at those as well
and if you do have any questions i would
love to answer
any questions or concerns that you might
have so that
all of you can join on monday
and learn with us about data science
so if you do have any questions please
put them in the chat
i will keep this slide on the screen for
just a few more minutes
and if you don't have any questions then
i welcome you to join
how do you actually join the program
so again this program is uh lbrn data
science
that is going to come up let me find it
okay for anyone that has concerns about
what will happen once you complete the
registration so what will happen is you
will see
the program like i do and you will be
able to see
inside all of the zoom links
as well as recorded videos from past
sessions you will see the included
courses and projects
in this program and you will also be
able to get a certificate for the
program
after you complete the necessary steps
which includes
some of the sessions that you need to
complete
and some of the coursework that we
provide
all right great thank you aviva and
great to see you
looking forward to seeing um
seeing a viva in the cohort
okay christine is asking would this be
the
program for intermediate level
experience with bioinformatics and its
applications to genomics and
transcriptomics yes
so again you can join the program as a
complete beginner
that's fine as well but mostly this is
for people that do
have some sense of what is this data and
what they want to do with this data so
if you
don't have a lot of experience with
genomics and transcriptomics data this
is a great program for you as well
but it will be talking a lot about the
technical details as well so you have to
be prepared
to you know i don't know christina if
you know any are
in python already or are you just
getting started
so maybe you could clarify that for me
hidayah is asking how many hours per day
so each session here and here you have a
schedule
each session is an hour and a half so an
hour of going through the lecture
materials and trying out different
things and then a half an hour that we
allocate towards q a so it's an hour and
a half
beyond this hour and a half a day you
also have
access to our slack channel and our
mentor community will be able to
assist you with any questions and if you
purchase the intermediate level
you can also book a meeting with one of
our mentors to help address one of the
questions that you have
okay so christina if you already have
some r experience and you're getting
started